[Music]
on this Tuesday night Russia's president
ramps up the rhetoric Vladimir Putin
digs in his heels as the U.S stands firm
Ukraine will never be a victory for
Russia
Russians robbing Ukraine of its culture
the battle to preserve and protect
Priceless Treasures Canada's inflation
rate takes another dip what could cause
it to climb again and Anthem adjustment
a small change
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight para Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us we
begin tonight with rivaling speeches
pushing two world powers further apart
U.S President Joe Biden and Russia's
President Vladimir Putin both pointed to
the other as the aggressor and
instigator for the war in Ukraine Biden
spoke in Poland hitting back at what
Putin said in his annual state of the
nation's speech in Moscow Putin
repeatedly blamed the West for the war
and said he is suspending the last
remaining arms agreement between the U.S
and Russia a landmark nuclear weapons
treaty
President Putin chose this war
every day the war continues is his
choice
he could end the war with the word
it's simple
if Russia stopped invading Ukraine it
would end the war
if you crane stop defending itself
against Russia would be the end of
Ukraine
standing in front of a large crowd in
Warsaw Biden spoke directly to the
people of Russia as he delivered that
Stark rebuke to Putin saying quote the
U.S does not seek to control or destroy
Russia and the West Was Not plotting to
attack Russia as Putin had said during
his address
nearly one year after the bombs began to
fall in Ukraine the American president
reiterated NATO's support for Ukraine
will not waver and kiev's allies will
not Tire Jackson prosco has our top
story tonight
in the country home to millions of
Ukrainian refugees U.S President Joe
Biden delivered a message of defiance
and unwavering support
the President Putin ordered his tanks to
Roland Ukraine he thought
we would roll over
he was wrong
he ranked the Ukrainian people are too
brave
one year after the unprovoked invasion
Ukraine and the West are savoring an
unexpected outcome Russia is on the back
foot isolated and bleeding reserves of
Manpower and Equipment the Democracy of
the world have grown stronger
not weaker
but the autocrat
IC Stronger Just 24 hours earlier Biden
stood in the very City Russia thought it
would topple within days of its
invasionally Russia's president made it
clear he's not giving up in a national
address Tuesday Vladimir Putin called
the war a local conflict claiming the
West seeks to turn it into a global
confrontation he warned the Russian
people to settle in for a long fight as
he made clear today he is preparing for
more war NATO is increasingly anxious
about what comes next a long slong
through a fresh Russian offensive that
could exhaust Western will and materials
and the possibility Russia May Harden
its own alliances we are also
increasingly concerned that China may be
planning to provide Elite and support
for Russia's War Putin's repeated
nuclear threats also took on new meaning
as he announced the suspension of the
new start treaty on weapons stockpiles
Russia says it will abide by treaty
limits on the number of warheads but
will not allow U.S and NATO inspectors
to access its weapon sites the
announcement by Russia that it's
suspending participation in New Start is
deeply unfortunate and irresponsible on
this day of dueling messages the tone
from both the U.S and Russia suggests
more of a stalemate than a fresh
escalation one year on the war is both a
test of resources and increasingly a
test of will
pharah Jackson prosco in Washington
thank you Jackson Biden made the journey
to Kiev by train and a little bit later
in our newscast a rare look inside
Ukraine's rail company a crucial
Lifeline for the nation through this
time of War
Russia's full-scale Invasion a year ago
this week was a land grab Putin
justifies the war by suggesting Ukraine
is not a real country despite Kiev
actually being hundreds of years older
than Moscow and we now know that Russian
forces have damaged or looted hundreds
of cultural sites in Ukraine from
museums to libraries Jeff sample reports
on the fight to save Ukraine's cultural
identity
this was the hersan regional Art Museum
before Russia's Invasion a top tourist
attraction home to one of Ukraine's
largest art collections fourteen
thousand pieces some centuries old
today the Museum's walls are bare
this museum is like the Louvre of
Ukraine says its director we have
nothing left they stole everything the
city of her son was occupied by Russian
forces for eight months until it was
liberated by Ukraine in November but
before the Russians left they looted
the Art Museum's deputy director says
staff moved most of the artifacts and
artwork down here to the basement for
safe keeping but one month before the
Russian Retreat a group of soldiers
arrived
they were accompanied by representatives
from the Russian Ministry of culture she
says they knew what they were doing she
says the Russians spent three days
prying the paintings out of their frames
and loading them into these trucks they
left almost nothing behind Ukrainian
officials and Museum staff say this
wasn't the work of a handful of Russian
soldiers who were simply looking to loot
some high-priced paintings but rather
they say it's part of a broader campaign
by the Russians to destroy Ukrainian
Heritage and culture Ukraine says
Russian forces have looted tens of
thousands of pieces from dozens of
museums and cultural institutions the
sheer scale of the art Heist drawing
comparisons to the Nazis in the second
world war and their plundered treasure
includes more than art
buried beneath this 18th century
Cathedral a crypt containing the tomb of
Russian prince yagiri potemkin so he was
buried here for more than 200 years the
founder of the city of her son lay here
for two centuries until last October
the Russian soldiers came and asked for
a tour the priest says then they
returned in the evening and told me to
open the Crypt he says the Russians
removed potemkin's bones in a cloth bag
and took them away
the Russians said they were taking the
remains to protect them because they
said the ukrainians were planning to
bomb the church he says but after they
fled it was the Russian army that turned
their big guns on her son
the priest showed us where the Russian
shelling hit in the yard outside the
cathedral the explosion shattered
windows and toppled the chandelier but
fortunately no one was hurt the
whereabouts of potemkin's bones are
unknown but some of the stolen artwork
has apparently turned up in
russian-occupied Crimea
these objects are proof of our Ukrainian
identity and history she says they're
trying to steal our heritage they want
to totally destroy it
but if that was indeed Russia's goal it
appears to be backfiring across Ukraine
Russian monuments and street names are
being removed
odessa's statue of Russian Empress
Catherine the Great was recently torn
down we found it replaced with a
Ukrainian flag and many including her
son's Art Museum director who used to
speak Russian have stopped
I felt like I was dying the Russians put
our paintings inside a filthy truck like
garbage she says speaking Ukrainian we
are going to get them back paintings and
artifacts can be stolen but Vladimir
Putin is discovering this country's
cultural heritage is not so easily
erased Jeff Semple Global News her son
the influx of Asylum Seekers entering
Quebec coming up how the province is
Atlantic neighbors are hoping to help
ease the pressure
44 people are now confirmed dead from
the devastating landslides and flooding
in Brazil residents are still digging
out from the torrent of mud and debris
that cascaded down hillsides when the
Heavy Rain pounded the southeastern
region of Sao Paulo State over the
weekend rescue teams are searching for
survivors in the destruction and still
hoping to find people alive dozens are
missing and nearly 2500 people are
displaced or homeless
Quebec Premier Francois Lago is calling
for the closure of an irregular border
crossing that's popular with Asylum
seekers in a letter published in the
globe and mail today Lego says the
number of would-be refugees entering his
province has exploded and he wants some
relief as Ross Lord reports Premier is
in Atlantic Canada are hoping to help
since regular traffic flow across the
Canada U.S border resumed more than a
year ago Quebec's irregular rocksome
road crossing has also been busier we
have a lot of people coming from Mexico
at the moment it does come in different
ways so where we're at now a lot of
people coming from Mexico from Venezuela
we are from the Congo Haiti Premier
Francois ago says quebecile more than 39
000 Asylum Seekers last year he says
it's overwhelming as province's Social
Services Lego launched prime minister
Justin Trudeau to renegotiate an
agreement with the U.S that opens the
door to migrants others are talking even
tougher conservatives are calling for
the prime minister to implement a plan
to close the roxam road crossing within
30 days from now the Atlantic provinces
which punched above their weight in
accepting Syrian and Ukrainian refugees
say they're willing to provide some help
in the case of New Brunswick about 150
or 200
um you know
individuals could be seeking asylum in
in our Province and and I think it is
it's a national obligation and we'll all
do our part it is heart-wrenching to see
those pitchers to see the Imaging uh the
images to hear the stories we've been
asked and yes we'll do what we what we
can for sure the premiers say they need
Federal support to do it properly we do
have significant challenges that we're
dealing with right now in terms of
housing availability a Montreal
organization that helps refugees settle
agrees planning is crucial that's
shifting migrants hastily would backfire
now you're just sort of putting them on
the bus with no conversation setting
them off somewhere where there may not
be appropriate resources keeping them in
a hotel for I don't know how long with
very little resources you're setting
yourself up for you know you have one
problem and then you're creating another
problem the federal government says it
recently transferred thousands of
migrants to Ontario to take pressure off
Quebec pursuing new Solutions while
preserving Canada's identity as a
welcoming country
Ross lore Global News Halifax
[Music]
singer Julie black
a Canadian performance at the NBA's
All-Star Weekend in Salt Lake City is
getting a lot of attention Toronto's
Julie black sang our national anthem but
her rendition changed a key word in the
song referencing Canada's I watched this
video a few times I just noticed right
now though that you looked right at the
camera when you said it so let me start
by asking you how did this come about
was it pre-planned
yeah so a few days before I was leaving
for Utah I I just felt this I just felt
impressed on my heart that I needed to
do something different and that would
take the light off of me in fact I have
indigenous friends I ran it by them uh
one in particular Roy Perot who's a
great friend and we worked together and
he felt good about it and I just needed
at least one trustworthy cosign and I
went with it
now you've sang the national anthem
countless times Canadians have heard you
why did you decide this was the moment
to change that keyword
well this is the global stage for the
for the Canadian national anthem like if
you think about it the Super Bowl is the
next biggest the biggest stage to Sing
the anthem and Canada isn't represented
there even though there are Canadian
football players whole other thing and
so I've turned the anthem down over the
years since 2020 with all that's going
on with indigenous rights and Truth and
Reconciliation I didn't feel that I was
prepared to stand behind the words but
having this opportunity having this
privilege as being Julie black being
chosen it was time for me to do
something there and and educate educate
to elevate it's kind of like if you know
you know to the Americans but all of
Canada knew
what kind of feedback have you been
getting
it's been beautifully positive
um there's the other trolls the trolls
actually make me laugh because these
keyboard gangsters I'm like come on come
on stop it the truth is I didn't in my
heart I didn't change the words of the
anthem the song The Anthem wasn't
correctly written to begin with so this
is what needs to happen it's a rewrite
hmm that's interesting do you want to
see this happen formally do you want to
see discussions for it to be formally
changed to happen
100 fairer I can't sing it the old way
and I'm not saying that it has to be
exact like you know changed completely
every single word but I think that with
a song that has so much history it's
important for us who are on today like
this is a new Time new generation to
really listen to it and say huh it's
like the Bible I read my phone could I
stand behind the scripture like someone
told me this scripture now I gotta learn
for myself same thing with this Anthem
that's how I'm treating it let me let me
really take these words in and see if I
could stand behind all of them
Julie black singing the anthem for the
first time since 2020 and changing the
words thanks so much for your time
[Music]
no excuses next why the Russian invasion
hasn't stopped Ukraine's National Rail
service
[Music]
the head of Ukraine's National Rail
service is calling the train that
carried Joe Biden to Kiev rail force one
it took the U.S president 10 hours to
reach the Ukrainian capital and another
10 hours to return by rail to Poland
over the last month Global News has been
granted special access to Ukraine's rail
company for a story that's airing this
weekend on the new reality as Mike
Armstrong reports the U.S president's
trip is just the latest example of how
the nation's Rail lines have managed to
deliver despite the ongoing War
there was a little frustration from
Alexander commission even on a day when
he moved to U.S president through a war
zone the head of Ukrainian Railways says
the VIP train meant juggling schedules
and other trains ran late
12 months since the Russian invasion
commission's motto has been War isn't an
excuse we never stopped because we had
to show that there is at least something
stable in the country
Ukrainian Railways has more than 230 000
employees commission calls them the iron
people they're as tough he says as the
rails they repair
or roll over that said it's been a
difficult year
we lost more than 300 Railway men and
more than 700 are injured but meanwhile
we keep standing and we will withstand
there was another example Tuesday of
what commission calls iron diplomacy the
Italian Prime Minister arrived in Kiev
by train the rail line has special
carriages that carry VIPs including last
spring Justin Trudeau now commission's
background is in finances he took over
the rail line just seven months before
The Invasion the job has been very
different from what he expected it was
managing a massive evacuation moving
refugees out of conflict zones and
giving orders that are almost
unthinkable
commission made his senior managers each
pick their replacement in case they're
killed no one he says is more important
than keeping Ukraine's train system
running well the real system saved
millions of people that's why it's
definitely more important than me
commission spends about half his time on
trains visiting areas close to the front
he says he wants Crews to know he would
never send them somewhere
wouldn't go himself
Mike Armstrong Global News
and you can watch Mike's full report
this Saturday at 7 pm on the new reality
and following that at 7 30 Global News
will Air a special to mark one year
since the full-scale Russian invasion of
Ukraine
and that's global national for this
Tuesday night I'm Farah Nasser on behalf
of our whole crew I want to thank you
for spending part of your evening with
us tonight's your Canada is Lake
Minnewanka near Banff Alberta we love
seeing your Canada so please email us
your photos to viewers
globalnational.com thanks for watching
join us back tomorrow until next time
take care of yourselves and take care of
each other good night
foreign
[Music]